[Music]
right now recording thank you
yes sir what are we doing right now
we're going to the Everglades holiday
park nice that's a new way of logging I
can see your whole face hmm
oh I thought so like at your role as a
harder mommy yes how are you there's
good you look majestic graded to make a
camera very close to going hot a pair
instead of bags I'm gonna bite what is
it you think you client to pick okay you
think too big oh yeah yeah yeah oh no no
let's not do that Aidan
[Music]
near each big cousin to the rescue hey
do you smell bag all right we're about
to mess up all of our hair we might lose
the Hat you might lose some sunglasses
and verb out the west by the wind my
hair I mean I III changers over with the
doesn't speak to the camera and let's go
back
[Music]
camouflage PR really has everything on
my histogram sorry minutes ago
investigated so I've have will be out of
a job the way to edit there's like way
both and my friend mr. Graham story
[Music]
like looking way out there but then you
comes afraid
and that
[Music]
yeah a lot along the way
[Music]
scary man having that guy's job I would
not be back even though they look like
they're super tame and again she's a
professional
even if I was a professional every like
Mac next morning for the first one good
morning okay he's a zombie
he needs good morning coffee there he
needs a graphical addition one
elliegator
holiday Safari ever so professional we
went to the Everglades today so that was
really I regret to write on their boat
and we had this one full cup and then
stroke this whole time that we've been
here
Isaac is kind of in like big brother
figure to Aden because you know he's
she's very willing to like help him like
buckle him in two years ago can I carry
him and I just did with Cooper and milk
and I've never seen Isaac that involved
with a younger kid before and this is
like the first time ever that you've
even around someone younger
and because you've always been the
youngest in whatever group were around
to justify but I could be like how let's
use the church as a kid because now he's
the one teaching eight in like no like
when you lie it's like this music trying
to explain I'm trying to come was like a
me like soldier all wrong in a daily
walk
what do you buy a cash cow even like
when they're playing around he's like
the big kids I could annoy juices
younger brother and I've never seen that
that kind of interaction with Isaac so
it's really endearing too because I get
like a little glimpse into the future
whenever we decide to have more kids in
the future that Isaac that's when he
really will be a big brother so to see
him you know having this preview of what
it's going to be like to be a trip
whether it's really really endearing and
it's also really really satisfying to
see him get so annoyed with a kid that's
younger than him that does exactly the
same annoying so that is pure tickler is
relentless it's really satisfying cuz
he's like then we absolutely me alone
like you know he does you just want to
talk to me all the time like that that
we were you do to us like every trip we
take he's constantly trying to like
tickle us he's constantly trying to like
kind on everything back I mean now blame
him because he is the only kid around us
so I think he has no other kids to play
with so she can only like the only
things that he can do is to you know bug
the adults it'll you know your cousin
now that they're coming younger than
hand that's doing the thinking to hand
out it's like ha I think I could do this
eventually throw in a couple years and
the third one so it makes me be alright
you can have in South Florida without
eating juban a booth and now we've got
the truncheon Cuban food and Little
Havana
[Music]
you don't like your in vanilla it tastes
really good
it's chimichurri
[Music]
all right I'm a crime on Oh
I think this might be the juiciest
motion report chunk I've ever had my
life
like Isaac I did so originally when
we're trying to find his restaurant so
you didn't miss me thanks put it away
all right so originally we were trying
to come to this restaurant
you were always 15 minutes away I was on
the yell plane and I keep the wrong I
was doing you do to me you always got me
helpful good
I'll go naturally fix man Louis's
restaurant where I keep the little
addresses of the window for you do it
the opposite direction
just a minute Tapia so and I mean a
45-minute Drive to get here but I think
it was all worth the 45 minutes and I
don't go bad you're helping your cousin
maybe you miss your big cousin just
moving his mouth
what does he what is he eating
[Music]
how eighty if you're eight years old
right now
hi so that's assume you want to be 13
little you I know how many more years
you have to go over now apply family
years so this is five years from now
yep so a future agent of five years from
now what else you wanted Aiden
we're kind of doing it's a little bit
and so love you baby for five years none
do you think you'll be friends of Aiden
and its future agent of you you're
sleeping right now Irishman I think so
call the show give it up we're losing
them okay once you're in law are you
remember that are you ready for that
I've been through that how are you
I am super ready for that comes in the
chariot okay if it does then you come
back because we're going to wake up in a
few hours to go to you're packing the
time like I like look here's my I really
[Music]
you know amazing anyway you cry cry cry
cry I play